c'est l'heure de discuter de ce qui est
passé sous le radar cette semaine mes
collègues marie
lem tremblay yves mano de nos bureaux
parlementaire de québec et d'ottawa
veillons au grain bon dimanche à vous
deux jours je commence avec vous bon les
travaux parlementaires on préfère
l'assemblée nationale
et comme toujours les annonces se sont
multipliées ce qui fait qu'il y en a
plusieurs qui sont passés inaperçus dont
une concernant les conditions de vie des
adultes hébergés dans des centres
d'hébergement de soins de longue durée
oui parce que les conditions de vie de
ces personnes qui habitent dans les
sièges celle des fonds souvent les
manchettes et pour de mauvaises raisons
parle souvent de manque de soins demande
de personnel ou encore de mauvaise
qualité de la nourriture alors en 2014
les membres de la commission de la santé
et des services sociaux se sont donné le
mandat justement d'étudier cette
question
ils ont reçu en commission parlementaire
une trentaine d'organismes intéressés
justement par les conditions de vie de
ces personnes mais là on pousse
l'exercice un peu plus loin on va
profiter des mois de décembre et de
janvier donc de la pause parlementaire
pour se rendre dans l'essai à chasser
l'idée est visitée justement certains de
ces établissements de la région de
québec et de la région de montréal
notamment
est ce qu'on veut faire c'est aller à la
rencontre des résidents mais aussi du
personnel et également des proches
aidants
ce qu'on veut vérifier donc sur le
terrain c'est voir justement si les
conditions de vie fonctionne bien et est
ce que tous les soins qui sont donnés
ils sont de façon respectueuse
alors on verra bien ce que ça va donner
mais chose certaine on veut voir
notamment si le financement correspond
au besoin si la formation des employés
est adéquat mais aussi justement si les
prochains dans toute l'aide dont ils ont
besoin
alors ce coup de sang sur le terrain
selon les membres de la commission qui
proviennent d'ailleurs de tous les
partis politiques
eh bien il estime justement que ça va
leur permettre de formuler des
recommandations plus juste et utilement
évidemment le choix c'est de faire en
sorte que les recommandations qui seront
déposés auront pour effet utilement
d'améliorer les conditions de vie de ces
personnes qui sont hébergées dans les
chu samedi peut-être de régler le
problème une fois pour toutes peut-on
l'espérer
merci on respire et oui yves de votre
côté à tahoua bon vieux le président du
sénat les eaux sa cause qui a perdu son
poste qui était remplacé par georges
thiéry
sinon on a moins parlé c'est que c'est
aussi arrivé quelques jours après qu'il
eut été montré du doigt pour avoir
supposément couler le rapport du
vérificateur général sur les dépenses de
sénateur voilà vous savez peu après les
élections on apprenait que leo housakos
aurait eu des discussions avec justin
trudeau qui lui aurait dit que son poste
n'était pas menacée à court terme qu'il
n'entrevoyait pas de faire des
changements la présidence du sénat or on
a appris jeudi dernier que qu'il avait
été remplacé par le sénateur furie mais
donc quelques jours auparavant c'est le
huffington post qui a dit que la source
des fuites du rapport du vérificateur
général en juin dernier sur les dépenses
des sénateurs que l'origine de cette
fuite était léo housakos et le
huffington post citait deux sources
anonymes de personnes qui disent avoir
vu léo housakos remettre des documents à
des médias et cette situation aurait
placé plusieurs sénateurs dans
l'embarras je quelques jours avant la
publication du rapport
et évidemment c'est suffisant que les
[ __ ] annonce que dès la première
réunion du comité de l'éthique
une motion sera déposée pour faire
enquête est-ce que c'est tout ça qui a
mis suffisamment les ou sa cause dans
l'eau chaude pour que justin trudeau
change d'idée et nomme un nouveau
président du sénat
peut-être mais à tout le moins on sait
qu'aujourd'hui les housakos n'est plus
président cheney
à vous de vous remercie d'avoir été des
nôtres merci